[Music]
first of all a lot of reality shows out
there you guys have hit the jackpot with
this one people love your show it's all
about how you started a duck dynasty
it's all about a multi-million dollar
business you guys created about making
duck calls that's fantastic
how did you start this business did you
start the business yeah I basically just
went out there and said you know I think
that we can make a better sounding duck
call that sounds closer to a duck oh
think that actually go out and do it
there's not a morning I don't wake up
until there's a better duck but you
actually wasn't so you were a duck
hunter and and there was one probably
duck call available you thought there
should be better ones is there we are
students of the sounds that Ducks make
it's amazing this is about six species
that we brought here since we kind of
cranking you up and starting you out as
a novice of course but there's always
hope for everyone you see so we're going
to give you about seven or eight species
of ducks and see if we can train you get
you downtown Louisiana you know get you
about a three or four-day Yasser Arafat
beard the high camo the shotgun saying
let's get up boy may not be three or
four days three or four years but okay
why so you just like I'll make a better
duck call you guys did and Phil you
started out making the duck calls and
then Willie you were the one you're the
CEO you're the the businessman I'll sell
the duck calls yeah it's my job okay he
makes them I sell them all right I want
to show a picture of you we just saw a
quick clip this is a photo of you guys
in your element on a duck hunt that is I
mean I had no idea that that this is how
duck hunters suit up
that is a very scary photograph hey tell
me about it when we go to airports in
the United States of America every time
they say you stand over there guess what
Phil I hope so
yeah that one and places my woman hasn't
been in it's America man all right
listen what are you not wearing that
are you wearing the camouflage
everywhere man you're worried you're
wearing the camouflage now and by the
way this camouflage isn't working in
this environment it's best to travel
incognito in my line of work however
when you go across the United States and
end up in Los Angeles California I said
not a good idea right so see where the
camouflage I mean you you walk around
with it a lot but when you're a business
meeting you wear a suit what do you wear
what's what's so funny Willie he doesn't
wear suits now I've never owned a suit
but you know I'm 65 I'm thinking you
know I believe I'll get all the way
through without that one by the way I
don't know I don't know self I'll never
have you've never owned a cell phone
never turned on okay notice you don't
worry you don't wear a watch no rings no
watches someone says well how in the
world you tell the time I said well I
would say right now when we would be
just darken a little bit
the here tonight just before daylight
good morning yeah okay you know we lost
on cloudy days right there's no idea
what time it is okay
well let's say you were gonna take me a
novice like me on a duck hunt
what would be the first thing that you
would do would it be my clothes what I
would you we would put black face paint
on you so that the Ducks couldn't see
and they would basically say on your
first trip sit down shut up and just and
watch the action so you would observe a
little bit there you know so till we
slow your shotgunning skills you know it
would be good even have me waving it all
around how do you know I'm not just
we're all come out of Harvard we're do
be sir would be a great duck hunter now
you said would I have to wear more
account more camouflage in the rest of
you guys Conan I mean would you say that
Conan O'Brien isn't he's not white he's
bright y mighty bright bright white and
the south we would say bright white I'm
like Rudolph I could late your way in
the fog my shining face my flaming hair